I'm Felix I'm going to just go dry jump
into it because I have a lot of material
to cover I'm Felix and principal
engineer at Microsoft and Apache spark
emitter so today I'm going to talk about
a bunch of design stuff but before we go
dad I'm going to talk about just a quick
introduction about myself I am patchy
Sparky meter I've been contributing to
spark for more than two years now I'm a
co-organizer of the Seattle spok meetup
which is local here welcome to kind of
join and check us out we have a lot of
interesting session and I'm also the
teaching assistant of the first massive
online course back in 2015 about spark
the two of them there's actually a bunch
of more now but back in your data it's
like like brand new and I also present
to also present at several meetup and
conferences so before we dive into the
content uh one quick disclaimer so what
I'm going to talk about today is largely
contributed by the community in fact
several different communities as we
talked about several different pieces
how it fit together and how how it
actually integrates part so quick agenda
for today I'm going to do a quick
introduction about into about spark and
PI spark and spa guard I wanted to going
to touch on how spark fit into the whole
machine learning puzzle here and that's
important because we dive as before we
dive into talking about spice PI spark
and spar and how you know you can do
machine learning or deep learning on it
you kind of want to know why you doing
it this way how all the pieces kind of
fit together and then we're going to
touch on you know the building machine
learning API that is available in Python
and R and we're going to talk about how
you can use the existing infrastructure
and talk to some of these packages you
are familiar with and leverage it to do
machine learning or deep learning
so I'm going to talk about how machine
is going to go over the world actually
no I'm going to add about spark today
it's kind of not as exciting it can ask
for quick shorthand how many of you
actually know what spark is okay maybe a
good quarter of it you know and then how
many of you actually use spark on a day
to day basis for the last you know a few
months for example okay not as much
so hopefully this this quick
introduction could be useful so you
might have already seen this diagram I
don't know seven thousand times but
spark is what a spark spark is this
general purpose cluster management
system which means that it could be
running a different type of workload on
this in a distributed manner on this
cluster you set up what's that kind of
interesting is it has over 1100 unique
contributor from the last from the last
few years over it is very popular
probably popular cluster system you know
that you use for all sort of different
things so it has to in this distributed
computing model so it has a client it
has a cluster manager it has a second
set of worker they managed it has
executive running on asian and they're
several tasks running potentially
Intelli and this you need a parallelism
is called a partition so these are kind
of some of these key concept idea that
will come back to several times during
this talk so hopefully you at least have
an idea what I'm talking about so what
are the ways to use spark so there are
people there are lots of different
companies or people engineer they're out
there using spark for several different
kind of ways you could be ingesting data
either from like reliable messaging
system like Kafka or just reading from
like storage you could be you know
taking this data and pass it through
some sort of ETL process right
using sequel using data frame
transformation and then you can leverage
something like catalyst optimizer for
optimizing your
thing leveraging tungsten leveraging
something like CBO which is new in 2.2
and 2.3 or you could be you know at the
end passing it through to a distributed
machine learning kind of pipeline and we
offer of course we were actually going
to be focusing on the delivery last part
here and we talked about kind of to
potentially very high level two
different approaches in a how that works
so let's start track a little bit talk
about the two language bindings so
language binding in this case in this
sense is like Python and R so let's
start with PI SPARC so part SPARC is the
Python API with handle a data frame that
you can inter interact with it
integrates with Pender's and numpy when
you have to serialize a function or you
know some closer capture that happens
it's done using calcloud pickle in terms
of architecture so you get the JVM
pieces in on the left hand side it
leverages PI for J using the PI for G a
gateway to interact between the JVM and
the Python processes and then it works
with the the remote process running on
the cluster the SPARC worker and then a
bunch of Python process managed by a
daemon process so the daemon process
using the daemon process kind of is the
the parent of all these actual Python
worker it does so by forking these
Python worker as needed
and then we talk about women half of us
are a little bit smug how is the our
language binding force part it exposes
functionality using something similar to
add applier alt apply or package it has
ripple if it's can be loaded as packages
in the IDE like ours you do
architectural is very similar to to
Python but instead of pipe oj there
isn't really something that we could use
in our so there is a proprietary you
know a complete different implementation
of of this serialization and
communication using soft get through
something running in the JVM call our
back-end you'll also have a bunch of
helper running in the JVM for somewhat
complex type of things like building an
ml pipeline we'll get to in a bit but at
a very high level is very similar so you
get the JVM process you get a bunch of
executor and worker running you get our
process running on the right hand side
so the interesting thing about Python
and are in this architecture overall is
the fact that most of the work actually
is executing in the JVM itself these
these wrapper classes are operating in
those languages but then most of the
heavy lifting is actually done in the
JVM so in this case you can leverage all
these optimizations being done in spark
in the JVM process like predicate
pushdown cogeneration all these new
things that happens there this is a
brand rack from actually a long time ago
but the idea here is show you there's
basically no performance penalty running
all these different language binding on
top of spark yourself and and the
important thing here is this is actually
going to be a recurring theme for the
stuff that will come back to a couple
times that you know we want to do the
heavy lifting in JVM
so where is spark fit in on these
machine learning puzzle so like I said I
want to kind of dive into a little bit
so that we have an idea going into
further into talking about the packages
and all these ml pipeline API is and how
works so imagine you have a end-to-end
data machine learning pipeline you get a
bunch of data from somewhere maybe from
data stream you ingest them you probably
want to do some pre-processing cleaning
the data a little bit deleting some of
these kind of you know garbage a doing
some ETL you know maybe aggregated or
join uh something else and then you've
had the two machine learning whether is
creating a training a model or maybe
doing predictions as we go and then some
of these insight you want to be able to
serve it and connect to something else
so why do I you know why do we even care
about spark then in this case can we
just do it this way like we can ingest
it we can run some ETL in some separate
process put it into storage and lets us
run some like analytics job or maybe a
machine learning job separately right
all that stuff will work well of course
this is going to work but one of the
kind of the recurring thing I've heard a
lot about is sometimes you wanna you
know you have some existing workflow
already in spark spark is really good
for with like ETL with all these
optimizations are happening sometimes
you want to be able to do this in one
single application right sometimes you
didn't want to do it in one single
language so you want to be able to do
this ETL in Python and then pass in to
some machine learning library and things
like that sometimes you want to be able
to you know sample the data or
aggregated you know do some kind of
massaging of the things before maybe
feature generation before passing to
machine learning so you need to do some
heavy lifting on the may be a you know a
really big set of data that you have and
sometimes you just want to run things at
a scale right swings in parallel many
many times so doing it in several
different jobs it's possible but it's
kind of a ripoff it's a it's a lot of
coordination that needs to happen and it
actually increases the iteration time
you know by having to like okay let's
get somebody to kind of do this ETL here
tons of data here and then you know come
back and do some more it takes maybe
weeks to do something so sometimes it
makes sense to do everything in spark so
so for instance right when you look at
let us say you have ingestion in spark
and you have ETL in spark you have
machine learning gear using the ml
pipeline model you can build in spark
and Python or and so on maybe you do
some iterative kind of things with ETL
like you different aggregate the data in
different level to see how it works and
then at the end you serve it and kind of
write it out to some you know precision
in some kind of key value store or maybe
no sequel database or something like
that but the serve part is kind of
outside spark so you see the gray box
here or maybe you use something else to
predict the do prediction on a new test
data coming in using something else
right so you can write out the model
that way so another variant of that is
perhaps not only you train the model
this way but you can also have maybe
even the same job or separate job that
takes the model and then do prediction
and then serve it so that's one approach
the other approach is well what if I
have all these charging and ETL and all
that stuff but then instead of doing
everything in spark I want to do it with
the library that I love and trust and I
know of I that I want to use that I
think is superior and so on and so forth
so you can then break your data into
pieces right and then run all these
machine learning either model training
in parallel and then you can even do
something like evaluate the model output
in power like see the watch one model is
has the best performance basically so
this is another version of running
things in parallel at scale another
third approach is you may have actually
trained a model in a separate separate
special setup say maybe you need a GPU
for it or maybe you need to have a
multi-core GPU very expensive running
somewhere to train a deep learning model
and this is somewhere in there and you
don't want to be doing this in the
cluster so you might take this approach
or tree free training the model you
ingest the data do your ETL processing
and so on take that data and then run
the prediction using the spark for
example and then just serve it again in
a very box with something else we're
going to export each of these a little
bit
so let's get to PI spark so pi Sparkle
data science before we start let's talk
a little bit about the spark ml pipeline
what is the spark ml pipeline it was
actually a relatively new thing it was
inspired by scikit-learn
so you can see a lot of these pipeline
concept is very similar to that you can
do pre software processing feature
extraction model fitting even do
validation or evaluation there a concept
like transformer estimator evaluator you
can even do things like cross validation
private parameter a tuning with
something like this so in other words
this this whole pipeline capture the
whole end-to-end sequence of stages and
step that you need for a machine
learning job so conceptually it looks
something like this you have a the input
data frame so somewhere you pass it to
maybe a sequence of transformer like
tokenizing the tags and do hashing you
feature generation through these step
and then you run through a model right
Lotus us in which is the estimator and
the NN you get a model that comes out of
this you can then you can take this
model to use it to apply it to new data
in a separate solar pipeline so spark ml
support a decent list of model I won't
say it's perfect I mean obviously has a
lot of trees is logistic question your
clustering
it has a kind of decent coverage on
almost a lot of things but one thing you
might notice is even though we have
multi-layer perceptron here MLP see it
lacks other newer network like CNN or RN
or LS cm or any kind of fancy anything
that's slightly more fancy here so
generally it is actually not go for
spark to have all sort of machine
learning models aboard do it so this is
how where this talks and what we're
going to be talking about kind of
fitting so but before we go there let us
say you have a you know a bunch of text
you want to kind of kind
see and analyze a little bit so you
tokenize the text you you know hash it
it's kind of the same pipeline we look
at already but this is a go and then you
set up the pipeline using these stages
so you can specify here right in the
order do you want and then you can use a
pipeline to chain this model that you
you have here and then the model can be
applied to test data and then do
prediction as a result so aside from the
spark API you can also use it to plug
into other pieces how we integrate other
packages and so on
but before we go there all this is kind
of mostly inspired by this paper in 2012
from Justin suggesting and all talking
about last scale who's talking about
deep learning but the key concept here
to extract out this is the idea around
model hellas immerses data parallelism
so spark could be used as a scheduler
this is a term that comes up pretty
often now these days so the idea is you
take your spark you have the data you do
your transformation but again you you
know remember that the diagram you look
at and you pipe it through other
external most likely native packages
somewhere you can use it for data
parallel tasks or you can use it for
distributed execution with the same set
data but executing you know training a
model in parallel for example so you def
is actually a great way to do that but
before we dive into you know how UDF
could be leveraged or you know something
similar you DF could be leveraged let's
explore a little bit about you DF so
there's actually several different ways
you can use you DF in SPARC you could
actually register a function you know
either anomalous like a lambda function
or actual function itself and then that
would be available in like sequel in the
sequel query or you can actually just
kind of pipe it through like a math
function or math partition the
interesting thing about this is UDF is
mostly a one-to-one thing basically it
takes a row
it applies UDA
and then you get something you know one
one roll at the end our PDF except for
map partition so this is something to
make an oval so that's generally the way
this works in high spark is something
like this you have executor you have a
worker here you get a partition that
whole petition gets serialize into
something called a row batch this whole
thing gets sent to the Python process
right because there is still two
different kind of processes running like
this JVM there is a Python process and
each of these roll get PSL and then send
to UDF for horses and then we get expect
to get a roll out of this as well and
then all the result gets utilized bag in
a badge and send it back to jail so the
rolls are executed in sequentially so
something to consider obviously this is
a lot overhead the not only is sending a
bunch of data around and it takes time
to do it and we also need to be
civilized package pickup and everything
and there's additional overhead with
multiple different languages and then
one thing to know is because you're
sending thing one at a time it actually
takes quite a bit of time to actually do
you know run a UDF so the good news is
there are actually several different
initiative in the community to address
that something like Apache arrow which
is in my memory column law for mac it
does the same thing like a row back
except the robot actually get exposed
directly to the native code so you can
actually have access to the entire batch
instead of running over time it does
things like zero copy in the future it
could do our kisi which means that
potentially there will be a reusable
copy in a sense you're actually not
sending things around that much
there is another zero in spark talking
about vectorize UDF so that's kind of
something to look at in future the
reason why I talk so much about this is
that we we we look at as we look at
native packages and how we integrate
spark and all these other things this
will come up time and again how data is
going to be transmitted and so on and so
forth
that sort of as a kind of the basis of
kind of some of the future things we're
going to be talking about very soon so
but to begin with the early days in 2016
there's a there's a package is the
library called spark SK learn the idea
here is to support running psychic learn
model module in Paulo you can use it for
training you know either a single node
mount parallel processing or very
seamlessly taking that and making it a
you know all running on a distributed
cluster setup unfortunately really what
it really does really well is just two
things research and G apply G apply is a
very interesting concept so the idea is
you you can organize your data in groups
and then look at the group as a whole
together that actually is going to come
back again so make a note of that so
there are obviously some other newer
things I'm going to explore several of
these new ones or maybe popular ones I
want people actually cover everything
under I will actually have a list at the
end to talk about several different kind
of either machine learning or deep
learning framework available but
something like cafe on spark the
interesting thing here is it's deeply
integrated in each of these executor it
has optimized execution with GPM GPUs
are running in the executor here and it
does interesting things like using out
DMA to sync model across all these
worker all of them outside Sparky so so
here is an example of what it looks like
one thing I won't actually highlight is
what do you see on the top here so you
have your predict caption function using
caffeine sparkvue all these other things
but you are the one responsible for
taking your data set and doing a map map
petition on it so that's actually why we
talk about math edition is the way they
were up to make a more efficient about
transmitting data to native code you
really want to do something like what
mathematician is doing
and there are things like Beck DL kind
of really similar architecture it does
similar things like a PDP all reduce and
the using block manager as a parameter
server it integrates deeply with the MLK
MLK library MLK anyway so it does few
things like reading other model and
leveraging model that is generated is so
something like a transfer learning type
of approach like I said you know you
also use Bach manager is the primary
server so you can leverage that as well
and here's the way that you would
potentially use big dl for like a CNN so
in this case you have the NS data set
with the handwriting digit here and you
can build a model like this so what kind
of looks very similar you can see on the
lower right hand side here how you can
build the optimizer and you can do
predict and it's kind of really similar
today the SPARC ml pipeline but the idea
here is you just need to pass in the
data set LD d in a training data in and
C in the middle here on the on the right
hand side and everything else is taken
care of for you so you don't have to do
the whole partition massaging all that
stuff there's another relatively new one
called mmm-mmm l SPARC is kind of hard
to remember how many MS are usually type
three so this is the spark ml pipeline
model it has enhancement like a
supporting Reacher type like images and
tax and so on
it also does deep learning with CNT k
undercover do kind of fancy things like
hey you can do training on a dedicated
GV GPU node and then transfer the
knowledge you know transfer model into
your cluster and so on and do things
like transfer learning that way
it leverages map petition and they
Native cover and you know it does you
know these things that very similar to
the SPARC ml pipeline model as you can
see in the right hand side in the sample
code and then there's sensor frame
how's the frame is been around much
longer it does things like high
performance tuning it also can apply a
training pre-training model s scale it
does roll and block operation on tenth
floor one thing that's interesting about
this this whole design or implementation
is that it does direct operation to a
native C++ code directly from JVM
bypassing the Python completely so
here's an example of what the code looks
like I won't dive into detail but the
highlight is actually the last line you
can see here you can directly operate on
the data frame you can do aggregation
and some and then you can pass it to a
tensor frame using a call like map lock
step going to apply that that hope
transformation on the block of data
itself and then there's this new thing
called Spock deep learning this is in
fact just announced a couple weeks ago
back in June in this box limit it
leverages this the previous tensor
framework so that's why we talk about in
this particular order it has similar ml
SPARC ml pipeline model it handles
things like it has support for image
data for example and you can do things
like DL feature ization transfer
learning one thing kind of interesting
about this is you can actually take the
model and then apply it as a sequel UDF
and then there's a future plan about
hyper parameter tuning so here's an
example some example what it looks like
so you can build predictor and then do
transformation like the pipeline model
that we talked about you can do you know
you can have a feature Iser to plug into
the ml pipeline directly or you can
register a a model that you build pv
ously and then just use equal to apply
your model that way and it does so using
the tensor frame map rows a function
internally which tries to translate to
mathematician as well so
the ecosystem around like it said
there's actually many more than I can
cover but these are the one that
actually has the Python api's so there's
dip this there's cafe on spark and a
sibling tensorflow and spark things like
a bunch of Apache project a project like
system ml hive mall MX net for example
there's a couple actually more prominent
or interesting one but there are like
JVM you know only and there's no Python
binding and so on so let's move on to
swagger so remember this we have this
slide we talked about spark ml pipeline
so in our this is actually done in a
slightly different ways so you have a
Lda api you see on the left hand side
you pass in text and you have some
parameter you can configure what it does
on a marker for you is it does the ml
pipeline for you so in the JVM once you
call this function it builds this
pipeline model automatically it create
this reject tokenizer and apply stop
words and then vectorize everything in
the coil da before so it's kind of
convenient to to call this api other
things like there are mobile model
operator you can use you can actually
create a take a look at the summary of
the data you have you can use this model
that you built and then apply it to to
make prediction on you new data coming
in using the predict call or you can
actually save the model that you train
maybe using in other languages as well
before we go further into understanding
how spar gar works with the pipeline
model one of the key concept here to
understand is this our formula that is
kind of unique in our so the idea here
is you you want to be able to simple a
user simple symbolic form to represent
your model that you want to do so the
example here is your respond are
why is model linearly by F 0 F 1 F 1 so
you can express your feature and your
label and target you know that way and
this is actually in fact implemented as
a feature transformer in course spark
which means you can actually use this in
Python as well there are other syntactic
sugar here for things like the label
column is automatically indexed for you
and then term columns are automatically
one hot encoded so you don't have to do
extra work for for massaging your data
set before sending it into the machining
model view so here is an example what it
looks like
so geo geo M is well one other thing
that we actually implement a two
variation of it there is one that
matches the our signature exactly and
then there's one that actually has
additional spark specific goodies and
you can kind of tune and use but in this
simple example is basically the same
slightly a different order parameter
zone but the core of this is what we
talked about in our formula you see here
where you specify the model the feature
that you want and to apply it to the
linear model you can also do things like
multi-layer perceptron you can define
them how many layers of it you know
hidden layers you want and all these
parameter you can tune there's also my
favorite random for us you can do
regression or classification on it and
then these are all the api's we talk
about but what if you want to do more
than just a whatever the 13 plus
actually more like I think more like 20
now different models are they supported
by swag are you can also use the native
UDF support so this is relatively a
relatively new thing there's some two
approaches you can apply remember what
we talked about G apply you can actually
do that in R as well the idea is you
take a data frame you take a spark data
frame converting to a native our data
frame pass it to your UDF and then we
expect to get back a data for native our
data frame back as well so
well the way this works is similar to
map petition except that this is
automatically done for you for each of
the partition you have it get all map
let's utilize into the our native data
frame send it to the center cross the
wire to the owl process to your UDF and
execute and then we expect to get back a
data frame back again and they get
civilize back to the JVM process all
that happened in Sioux and tallow so you
have these similar to the our apply
function we have ad apply function it
takes to spark data frame and you can
specify this nominal function here and
you can manipulate these columns and
process it there's a variation of this
so we're going to be taking back the
native data frame without having you to
specify the scheme of the output so you
can do whatever you want and we'll get
you the native data frame so you can
play around with so here's a deeper
example of this so you can take a DF
like elect and then in this case I'm
calling the are random forest function
you know you can specify very similar to
what we did before you can specify a
formula here and then I'm going to
predict on the test data set coming in
so the interesting thing about this is
this is actually not defined inside the
scope we were talking about here this is
a test data set that get captured
because of cultural capture support in
spa gar and automatically civilize the
broadcast to all the executor
automatically for you and then again we
pick the in prediction and send it back
to whoever is calling this and then we
can evaluate the performance of this the
you know random forest there are another
way to do this we talked about G apply
you can then say hey I want to take this
buck data frame and then group it by
this column that I have here and then
the UDF would get back similar things
with data frame except the data is
already a group appropriately with the
grouping columns you can apply more than
one the way you want it
and there's a slight variation that is G
applied so couple of considerations spa
goddess right now doesn't support nested
structure there's also one thing to be
clean Keaney aware of is the issue with
data skew when you group something you
partition something your data could be
skew towards particular partition so
what if your partition or group becomes
too big for the our process so sometimes
or even Python even in this case right
so you need to be a work how your data
what is the shape of your data and what
it looks like there's also a flip side
of the problem what if you don't get
enough data or not having the enough
variety that you need to actually build
a machine involve others and then we
talk about performance costs cost wise
overhead around utilization data
transfer and so on we talked about
closer capture to so something to be
aware that you're not actually
accidentally sending a lot of data
around and then managing packages like
random forests so some other our
packages is something that we heard a
lot of feedback on it's something that
you need to be aware how they handle
that there's also one additional way to
do this so there's also L apply support
in spa car so it's really good for these
embarrassingly parallel tasks so when
you do what you want to do hyper
parameter tunings on the idea here is to
take a native Arliss and then distribute
it in processing whatever you use DF is
doing and then we get whatever you DF is
returning and send it back to you so
here's a more concrete example it looks
like so I'm generating a list of cost
value here right and then I'm sending it
through this training function that I
define here that calling SVM similar our
formula we've seen here this is actually
not part of spark but this is your
native you know SVM function and then
you can call spark our apply like this
they will just paralyze the processing
you and then you can figure out what
cost value actually makes sense that you
know generate the best performance here
is another more concrete example
unfortunately it's kind of really hard
to fit the entire thing in in the sides
part going to take like I know maybe ten
slides of it but the general idea here
is you can do something like ten set
over here as well so this is actually
the our studio tensile flow are binding
that is released recently so you can
load the tensor flow library
unfortunately it's kind of really
similar sounding name but this is our
library which you can trust me on that
and then you can create this you know
tensile force s room and then you can
use it for training this data set this
is in this case we're looking at the m
list data set again for the handwriting
and then you can use something like a
convolution neural network we trained it
but for instance you want to train a
20,000 times it's kind of hard to do it
in a sequence rate we're going to take
you know quite a long time to train
others but what if you can actually
leverage spark for doing this in Palo
and doing in a distributed manner so
this is kind of the way to do that one
thing I want to touch on is I won't go
into the details of it the goal here is
actually making SPARC available as a
package what's kind of interesting
though I do want to highlight is
actually at the very bottom what it
means is you can in fact leverage Spock
are to control the JVM not just any
other JVM but talk to spark directly
calling into its method you know calling
to kind of the spark context and all
these things to control remote details
so the hope years ago here is hopefully
community can actually write more
packages on top of spark there's
actually a few already out there and
we're going to touch on that quickly but
you know that's kind of what we're
looking at so that's actually kind of
wrapping up the the are aspect of it
there's actually several different
alternatives you can you might have
already heard of there's a sparkly are
from our studio xeo has deep learning
packages that works a spark as well as
our binding
Susa memo has a our light api but it's
not quite what the next line is actually
going to be this is our 4 ml which is
from several months ago it was just
announced back in February I think it
actually seamlessly integrates to some
ml and spa Garr underneath the cover so
it this is in fact for example one one
approach where a package could also
depends on this bar guard and there's
also something like patch in the mix net
which also has our binding so to recap
you could also just let spark take care
of things or you can call into packages
one thing you want to be aware of is to
be aware of your partition where things
are how things go and there are many
many effort here trying to make that
kind of really efficient and talking to
packages in integrating native code and
that sort of thing
all right thank you that's that I'm open
up for question thank you thank you very
much Felix yeah just everyone else is
10:40 so if you want to get to another
session you have five minutes otherwise
please stay so while I let question you
should take some look and I will take
questions for the next five minutes
while people transition go ahead
wait well thank you oh yeah of course
this would be part of the conference
part of the information there and feel
free to reach out to me for more
information about how these things works
and how do you leverage it you know
these are the information that would be
in a DAC so when you find it that you
can find me and preview just simply I'm
really really open and happy to engage
with people that are using spark and so
on
thank you so okay I got for the question
obviously there are a lot of frameworks
for sparks it's a lot of ways to go
about primarily tattoo you know do you
have any personal preferences are these
a good or how about this what's a good
framework for other Python or r2 least
get started with them allows you to work
with and not quite maybe not all the
bells and whistles but at least enough
to at least get starting going without
having to get bogged down right that is
the interesting question I mean I think
the minimum we kind of skip quite a bit
is in terms of the data misogynist back
of this right this is slightly out of
scope of this top but often time you
want to be at least some getting
something other with like how that data
frame operation works okay so maybe you
want to learn about tenders or spark or
our data frames just kind of know how to
work with us but I I don't I mean I'm
kind of biased I think you should use
swag are because I'm the primary kind of
kind of owner of it and I love people
are using it and I feel like you know
our is such a you know huge community
out there but this is look like high
data comes we welcome everyone is myself
so there's always the debate instruct of
hi hi home horses alright but Python
actually has a lot of potential way so
you can see here a good portion with
this talk talking about how Python has
all these high-level packages you can
leverage to very easily kind of like you
can't forget about the fact that you're
using spark at all just like hey I'm
going to be doing a tensor frames are a
tensor flow here right with some
overhead you how do you get the data
into the shape you want it
Oh
so ever that yeah and then and then
moving on from there so I mean I would
recommend kind of subtle than that if
you already from all of some of these
packages are there and start from being
something that you already from low wave
and and in something that kind of bridge
into sparks okay
Twitter is not refreshing the way I
needed to refresh right now so there's
no question that's good luck so so what
we live obviously up yeah I had a
general question of just out of interest
what is the journal balance in the
community of like spark users versus
Python users versus our users is like
literally a third third or just how it's
interesting so there's been a research
done by data bricks so the people that
kind of create a spark as a company reek
of is coming as a person companies on
they had a research in terms of from
their customer base I think they're
talking about about same for Scala and
Python but about 10% for four hours so
it's kind of less on the outside there's
actually quite a bit of Python in it -
user it's not using but if you go beyond
a spark space I would say I mean it I've
seen number of resources it stays
basically same number of people using
Python and are pretty equally and that's
kind of kind of why I structure the top
this way there's kind of half and half
is nice so well what can take you Felix
Lauren thank you I can yes two o'clock